so many years ago when I was 21 years
old I was at Sherman Oaks California
having lunch with this guy named David
who was a very successful business guy
and we're sitting then he showed me his
account he says here's seven million
dollars I said seven million dollars for
a 21 year old kid who had never seen
seventy thousand dollars that was just
absolutely amazing to me and I said so
how did you make your money he says
Patrick do you know why US Jewish
business people keep making so much
money I said no but I'm assuming you
gonna tongue he said yes he said the key
to Jewish people is the following when
the one of us makes money a lot of us
make money because we make money
together so what happens is we keep
doing business together because we know
if I do business with David guess what
he's gonna make money and I want to make
money he says unfortunately some
communities the way they want to make
money is only I make money this is my
business this is my company this is my
office this is Midas and the more you go
that way people don't want to do
business with you but the more you share
and you continuously make money with
other people here after year after year
you make that phone call people say what
are we doing next let's do it again
let's do it again let's do it again
because they know one thing if they team
up with you they know you're gonna make
money and they know they're gonna make
money